Vice news is going out of business
[Music]
I know I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to say look we want healthy
dialogue in this country and it's sad
even though I'm not on their side of the
aisle I'm very sad that there we don't
have robust there's no robust dialogue I
want Vice and I want all of those other
stupid magazines I want it to to be
disbanded I want them to go bankrupt I
want their product to be ground into
dirt
I want that dirt to be buried deep
underground and I I want to never see it
or hear about it again that's what I
want I can't help but notice Vice news
attacked me Vice news smeared me and
insinuated that I'm a genocidal Maniac
over my CPAC speech and then two months
later they go out of business is that a
coincidence coincidence I think not
probably but it's a delightful
coincidence nevertheless